wir machen weiter mit bildern aus
deutschland die man so eigentlich
überhaupt nicht kennt aber über die wir
dringend sprechen müssen
vor einigen stunden hat uns dieses video
aus frankfurt am main erreicht brutale
aufnahmen einer festnahme aus
sachsenhausen sorgen im netz für große
aufregung ein junger mann liegt hilflos
am boden polizeibeamte knien auf ihn
fangen an ihn zu schlagen dann rand
einer der polizisten seinen knien seinen
rücken
der junge mann kann sich nicht wehren
und schreit vor schmerzen
andere polizisten halten die umstehenden
passanten davon ab dazwischen zu gehen
doch einer der anwesenden film den
brutalen einsatz mit seinem handy dann
tritt ein anderer beamter mit seinem fuß
auf die hilflose person am boden ein
doch seine kollegen gehen dazwischen und
stoßen den beamten vom geschehen weg auf
twitter schreibt die polizei dass der
vorfall bekannt sei es laufen derzeit
zwei ermittlungsverfahren in dieser
sache mehr wollte sie nicht preisgeben
die stimmung ist aufgeheizt nach etwas
mehr als drei minuten wird der junge
mann in handschellen abgeführt warum es
zu der festnahme kam ist noch unklar
und es gibt noch ein zweites video aus
düsseldorf das für aufregung sorgt und
zwar diese bilder
wir sehen ein polizist kniet auf dem
hals eines mannes und ja sofort denken
wir natürlich an das was dort ende mai
passiert ist und wie jetzt bekannt wurde
das opfer das wir hier sehen dass es
gerade mal 15 jahre alt wie konnte
dieser polizeieinsatz so enden und mir
jetzt zugeschaltet ist michael mertens
von der polizeigewerkschaft herr mertens
vielen dank dass sie sich die zeit
nehmen sie kennen die aufnahmen aus
düsseldorf ja sicherlich auch meine
erste frage ist denn so eine methode wie
wir sie da sehen in deutschland
überhaupt erlaubt genau dieses
einschalten wird so bei der polizei in
nrw trainiert wenn jemand am boden
fixiert wird
die zweite person die aufgabe den kopf
zu fixieren in dem knie und schieben
beiden das tun wir aber nicht mit der
gesamten körper das auf der person
sondern eben nur so viel druck wie es
notwendig ist das ganze nur deswegen
gemacht und zwei dienst
erreichen einmal dass die person nicht
mehr beißen und spucken kann aber das
zweite ist mindestens genauso wichtig
die person versucht gibt personen die
versuchen dank mit dem kopf selber auf
den boden zu schlagen sich dabei zu
verletzen und so quasi die festnahme zu
verhindern
und deswegen macht man eine solche
option wenn sie die bilder aus
düsseldorf jetzt sehen war diese
festnahme beziehungsweise sowie die
beamten mit demjenigen umgegangen sind
war das gerechtfertigt die bilder die
mir jetzt sieht sieht man ja nur die
festnahme als akt ob diese maßnahmen
gerechtfertigt war oder ist muss der
sachverhalt hergeben was da passiert ist
und warum die kollegen so eingeschritten
irgendwas geben diese wenige sekunden
der aufnahme gar nicht und das muss auch
abschließend geklärt werden dort hatten
wir bleiben bei dem fall mir jetzt
zugeschaltet bild chefreporter frank
schneider frank wir haben die bilder
gesehen zwei solcher brutalen szenen am
wochenende polizeigewalt ist man in
deutschland ja eigentlich nicht gewöhnt
ist das jetzt ist das jetzt der
normalfall oder wussten sich die beamten
nicht anders zu helfen und wie kann man
das einschätzen
ja man muss erstmal glaube ich
differenzieren es handelt sich hier um
wirklich zwei anders gelagerte fälle
erst mal sind es zwei einzelfälle
der vorsitzende gewerkschaft der polizei
eben auch gesagt man weiß nicht was
davor passiert das ist ja häufig bei
diesen videos der fall die im netz
auftaucht man sich dann immer erst wenn
die polizei aktiv werden nicht was
vorher passiert ist weil der frankfurter
szene die wir hier gerade nochmal sehen
muss man ja wirklich sagen dort tritt
ein beamter in rain in denen den
tatverdächtigen der am boden liegt und
dann kommt ja auch sofort ein zweiter
beamter schiebt ihn weg spricht auch
hinein und nochmal ein weiterer beamter
spricht auch mit ihm und schiebt ihn weg
dann sehen sieht man schon die auch die
anderen damen waren der meinung das war
nicht gerechtfertigt
man muss auch wissen es nennt sich
juristisch ein bisschen komisch
formuliert mit dem beschuhten fuß
also spricht mit einem schuh am fuß auf
jemanden einzutreten nennt man auch
gefährliche körperverletzung das ist
schon schwierigen nach vorwurf die
person wehrt sich in dem moment gefühlt
nicht und da muss man sicherlich klären
ich glaube dass das für den wagen
möglicherweise ganz
folgen hat bei der sache in düsseldorf
dies etwas anders gelagert muss man
sagen da handelt es sich ja wirklich um
eine festnahme technik und da ist ja
wirklich nur zu klären
war das angemessen oder nicht dort wird
ja der verdächtige nicht geschlagen
man muss vielleicht auch damals sagen im
vorhinein es folgendes passiert zehn
personen randalieren bei mcdonald's die
polizei war mit mehreren streifenwagen
dorthin gerufen entsprechenden
platzverweise aus bringen die menge
sozusagen wieder zur saison und dann
kommt dieser 15 jährige der eigentlich
gar nichts mit dem vorfall zu tun hat
über die polizisten und schlägt dann auf
einen polizisten ein
das zeigt so ein bisschen das im
vorhinein dort passiert ist war auch
sehr ungewöhnlich
man muss jetzt wie gesagt klären das ist
auf diesem video in den winkel nicht
eindeutig zu sehen wo kniet er genau das
einzig gute an der geschichte kann man
jeweils in düsseldorf sagen der
15-jährige hat keinerlei schwerwiegende
verletzungen erlitten vermutlich sogar
gar keine verletzung hat sich selber
schon im internet gezeigt
der beamte hat ihn jetzt nicht so in
irgendeiner form verletzt dass es wie
gesagt natürlich wirklich brisant gerade
mit dem hals und sollte auf dem alles
gekippt haben egal auch wenn jetzt
nichts passiert ist ist das natürlich zu
an und dann wird zwar strafrechtlich und
disziplinarrechtliche folgen aber wie
gesagt die beiden fälle
die muss man schon differenzieren von
der vorgehensweise der beamten sind das
zwei ganz anders gelagerte fälle